That's enough, come on out, Mr. Rossi.
How did you find out? It's embarrassing.
Did I do something to earn you a grudge? If the
fate is 0 yen, why do you stand out even more than me, who is targeting me?
It's not
enough, but I do
n't think I'm more conspicuous than Nanao.You little
girl doesn't care about the small details.
In a sword fight without spells, the two magic spells are prints.I don't care if the
team is fast or not even if I get cut.Let's take it.If I'm in the mood, let's get
started.I
forgot to mention one thing, but it's still the teacher.On
the other hand, I  I don't like the fact that it's bad manners to use a sword, but every time I
learn a skill, I think there's a faster way.
This aircraft
is not as good as it sounds. It's annoying.
[Music] [
Music] I didn't expect it to
happen, but I put something like this on it. Don't you
think it's strange that they don't hit each other? The point is, if we were going to
kill each other, we'd have to do everything we could.
Thank you, Mr., for
someone like you who is now acutely aware of your own immaturity,
you're telling me not to do this.I'm
still getting beat up, so that's impossible.From now on,
even if I don't post it, your case will be destroyed.